bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà ce que l'on
peut retenir en ce jeudi 17 mars la
restructuration des deux cinémas de
versaillais à l'étude un multiplexe de 9
salles pourraient voir le jour en
centre-ville le projet en est assez
début chez les détails dans quelques
instants les départementales c'est J-5
nous intéressons ce soir au canton de
Saint-Cyr-l'École qui verra entre autres
l'opposition entre le conseiller général
sortant le socialiste Jean-Philippe
Mallet et le nouveau maire de
Bois-d'Arcy Philippe Benassaya qui avait
fait basculer la ville à droite au
dernière municipales un coloc se déroule
demain à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin pour dresser le bilan de
la loi Hamon un an après nous faisons le
point avec notre invité Philippe fleuret
de l'UFC Que Choisir mais d'abord en ce
mardi enfin dans 17 mars ces images des
collégiens de Trappes du village Gustave
Courbet et Youri Gagarine invité lundi
au ministère de la Culture pour un match
d'improvisation sous les dorures et les
grands miroirs du Salon des maréchaux
une patinoire rouge tu as pris place où
s'affrontait à des équipes de 6 joueurs
tous participent aux ateliers animés par
la compagnie Déclic Théâtre
l'improvisation théâtrale qui prend
ainsi ses lettres de noblesse c'est
d'ailleurs une discipline qui fait
maintenant partie des activités
artistiques proposées dans les
établissements scolaires une belle
reconnaissance
politique maintenant tous les soirs de
la semaine nous nous intéressons quand
on de notre secteur ce soir le canton de
Saint-Cyr-l'École qui compte notamment
les communes de Saint-Cyr-l'École et de
Bois-d'Arcy et qui verra entre autres
l'opposition entre le conseiller général
sortant le socialiste Jean-Philippe
Mallet est le nouveau maire de
Bois-d'Arcy Philippe Benassaya UMP qui
avait fait basculer la ville à droite
aux dernières municipales Lionel Thorez
fait le point
en craie à gauche depuis 17 années
consécutives le canton de
Saint-Cyr-l'École comprend actuellement
si communes Bois-d'Arcy Chavenay
Fontenay fleuri reine moulins Villepreux
et Saint-Cyr-l'École ancien député et
conseillé général sortant socialiste
Jean-Philippe Mallet se présente cette
année avec son binôme Fabienne gel
gombilbo conseillère municipal de
Villepreux il se bat notamment pour un
pluralisme politique dans le département
qui l'estime nécessaire vous savez le
président du Conseil général des
Yvelines pierre Bédié dit partout que la
droite peut faire le Grand Chelem et
donc je pose la question aux Yvelines
est-ce qu'il est saint pour une
collectivité pour la bonne marche d'une
collectivité pour la démocratie locale
qu'il y ait une assemblée départementale
l'assemblée d'une collectivité
territoriale monocollant d'une seule
couleur politique uniquement gérer et
aller depuis longtemps par l'UMP je ne
pense pas parmi les principaux dossiers
dans lesquels il souhaite continuer à
s'impliquer la création de logements
dans le cadre de la loi du Grand Paris
mais aussi le dossier de mélange en ciel
ouest ces transports en commun qui
devraient relier la gare de
Saint-Cyr-l'École à la gare de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye avant d'être relié
à Achères par la suite un projet portait
notamment par l'État la Région
Île-de-France et le département des
Yvelines Philippe Benassaya actuellement
de Bois-d'Arcy a su faire basculer sa
ville à droite aux élections municipales
l'année dernière avec son binôme
soniabro premier adjote au maire de
Saint-Cyr-l'École il compte bien ne pas
s'arrêter là et transformer les C sur le
canton de Saint-Cyr pour la première
fois j'ai le soutien et nous avons le
soutien avec soniabro de tous les maires
du canton et ça c'est une situation
exceptionnelle qu'on n'a jamais connue
que sur la droite ou à gauche quand le
canton était à droite ou à gauche on n'a
jamais connu cela sur ce canton soutenu
par tous les maires du canton Philippe
Benassaya n'hésite pas également à
mettre en avant son expérience du
terrain plusieurs axes de campagne sont
cités c'est la voirie c'est la
circulation les transports et surtout
pour nous à Bois-d'Arcy la réussite
éducative le numérique
ça c'est important et bien sûr tout ce
qui touche les familles l'aide au
handicap les seniors et tout cela et ça
ce sont des pistes très importantes pour
notre canton dans ce canton trois autres
listes se présentent Dalila voudrais et
Jean-Yves Maximilien au nom du Front de
Gauche europécologie les Verts Julien
Grimm et Perrine Jugnot pour le FN et
Sylvia quant à l'oupi avec Christophe
Pitel pour debout la France en 2008
Jean-Philippe Mallet l'avait remporté au
second tour face à Jean-François
Lasserre le maire de Fontenay-le-Fleury
avec 58,7% des suffrages
la restructuration des deux cinémas à
Versailles est à l'étude le propriétaire
exploitant à souhaiter trouver un
repreneur un projet vient d'être
présenté passer de 12 à 16 salles
conservées le Cyrano et transférer le
Roxane sous le parking Europe tous les
détails
une page pourrait se tourner pour les
deux cinémas versaillais le Roxane et le
Cyrano l'exploitant historique ne peut
plus assurer les investissements amener
et ils souhaitent céder son activité mes
parents sont arrivés ici à la fin de la
guerre ils ont repris l'activité du
cinéma Cyrano à l'époque ils en ont
acheté les murs enfin bon il y a eu une
longue longue histoire et il faut que ça
s'arrête un jour tout ça est lourd à
porter long un pas loin développé et bon
moi j'ai 71 ans le repreneur potentiel
la société CGR cinéma plus de 40 salles
en France surtout en province et
quelques implantations en région
parisienne dont une à Mantes-la-Jolie le
projet se définit en deux phases le
Cyrano serait conservé c'est dans ce
cinéma que les Beatles avaient fait leur
premier concert il sera remis au goût du
jour et notamment permettra une
meilleure accessibilité le Roxane lui
sera fermé et à nouveau cinéma multiplex
réalisé sous le parking Europe c'est
fondamentalement bien sûr à un projet
privé la ville
parce que elle a quelque part mis des
conditions qui étaient d'une part le
maintien des cinémas en centre-ville
deuxième condition c'était si possible
de garder le cinéma historique du Cyrano
et puis vous savez les villes sont un
peu incontournables dans ce type de
projet parce que il y a des règles
d'urbanisme à respecter et en
l'occurrence le terrain derrière la
poste était la propriété la ville ce qui
au final offrira ses salles de cinéma au
lieu de 12 actuellement avec une offre
de programmation diversifiée assure le
futur exploitant je reste que vous
connaissez aujourd'hui si ils veulent
même étendu ça va être étendu puisqu'on
va alors ramener toute l'activité du
Roxane qui aujourd'hui sur quatre salles
au cinéma Cyrano Cana 7 je ne dis pas
que les 7 vont passer de la réussite il
y en a eu d'ailleurs pardon je n'ai pas
que les vides vont passer de l'arrêter
mais effectivement on va pouvoir élargir
à 5,6 salles un peu à la demande c'est à
dire s'il y a du film important en a
assez et qui nécessite une programmation
un peu plus étendue en prof autant de
salles mais l'avantage d'avoir 16 ou 17
salles sur la ville va permettre
effectivement d'une part détendre la
programmation à essai et détendre aussi
la programmation commerciale
actuellement le Cyrano accueille 400 000
spectateurs à l'année avec cette
restructure la société CGR table sur un
million d'entrée annuelles avant la
réalisation du projet qui pourrait voir
le jour fin 2017 des étapes cruciales
sont à passer comme le dépôt d'ici un
mois du dossier devant la commission
départementale d'aménagement commercial
la CDAC devrait donner ou non son accord
à ses travaux
demain mercredi un colloque se déroule à
la Faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin un coloc pour dresser le
bilan de la loi à mon un an après sa
mise en pratique alors qu'est-ce que
cela a pu changer pour les consommateurs
nous posons la question à Philippe
fleuret bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'UFC Que Choisir de Versailles et sa
région la loi Hamon un an après c'est
quoi l'élément fort de cette loi
l'élément fort c'est que désormais des
consommateurs peuvent obtenir
satisfaction
ils ont tenu à droite qui n'avaient pas
auparavant sans les accents de groupe
les actions de groupe
en place de cette loi il y a eu quatre
actions de groupe qui concernaient
notamment les domaines de l'immobilier
banquier et assurance c'est quoi une
action de groupe comment on peut
s'organiser ça veut dire qu'on est
consommateurs on se réunit on est une
vingtaine et hop on y va où c'est plus
compliqué plus subtil que ça permet à
des consommateurs qui ont un litige qui
sont victimes donc d'un abus d'une
entreprise d'une société de et à travers
une association de consommateurs une des
cases consommateurs agréé par la loi
donc de faire valoir leur droit en
justice il faut être un nombre minimum
où il y a sur deux personnes ça suffit
mais il faut passer par une association
de consommateurs c'était une demande qui
était depuis au moins une vingtaine
d'années
parce que bon il y avait des différentes
contraintes si vous voulez
mais ce que je peux dire c'est que bon
que les consommateurs étaient étaient
vraiment démunis face au comportement de
d'entreprises qui abusaient les grandes
entreprises je peux citer des dans le
monde par exemple de la de la téléphonie
dans le monde bancaire par exemple ou de
l'énergie et des groupes très très
puissants et les consommateurs étaient
complètement démunies face à certains
comportement
quand on pense à action de groupe on
pense surtout aux classes actions à
l'américaine on entend souvent parler
dans les médias parce que forcément
elles sont même capables de mettre au
pylori une entreprise est-ce qu'il y a
une différence fondamentale entre les
actions de groupe à la française et la
classe actionne à l'américaine
le système français il est plus
équilibré et plus mesuré
l'essentiel pour nous c'est que les
consommateurs les ai est satisfaction
alors qu'aux États-Unis la catastroix
peut très bien aboutir à mettre en
difficulté d'entreprise ce qui est pas
le plus en France et également aussi
permettre l'enrichissement par exemple
de certains avocats ce qui est pas le
but non plus en France c'est pas
autorisé ou ça pourrait être c'est pas
possible
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible et
donc c'est mieux comme ça oui c'est
encadré à la française alors la loi
d'amont ce ne sont pas que des actions
de rouge vous attend de qu'on s'arrête
quelques instants pour savoir ce qu'il
reste encore à faire dans cette loi et
pour cela nous sommes allés poser la
question tout bonnement à Benoît Hamon
le député des Yvelines donc c'est lui
qui a donné son nom à cette loi
lorsqu'il était ministre de la
consommation
les seules choses qui sont pas encore en
place je vous le dire c'est les parkings
les parkings on tarifs auparavant une
heure maintenant ce sera aucun quart
d'heure ça c'est pour avant l'été la
résiliation la possibilité de résilier
son assurance auto ou
habitation ça va pouvoir dès le premier
janvier de l'année prochaine on pourra
le faire
l'action de groupe c'est déjà en place
les dispositions qui permettent qui font
en sorte que la garantie sur les
produits que vous achetez passe de 6
mois à deux ans se mettent en oeuvre bon
voilà le support à peu près je crois 80%
des des articles votés dans la loi les
décrets ont été publiés et la loi
s'applique c'est la possibilité
désormais d'avoir un délai plus long
pour se rétracter quand on achète en
ligne il y a beaucoup de Français
aujourd'hui qui achètent sur internet ce
sont des droites consommateurs mieux
protégés
alors 80% de des propositions de loi on
fait l'objet d'un décret est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est satisfaisant pour
FC que choisir cette loi bien sûr
qui ont répondu à des souhaits que nous
avions déjà depuis très très nombreuses
années pour revenir au classic actions à
l'action de groupe disons tel qu'elle
est prévue dans la loi il y a un autre
sens de point faible c'est le problème
des preuves qui sont vraiment il faut
que les
preuves et donc parfois c'est difficile
de garder des tickets de caisse donc on
incite les gens à regarder tickets de
casse ça c'est le premier point et puis
la liquidation aussi des
des indemnités en cas de sanction donc
doit se faire liquidation des indemnités
pas des indemnités mais si vous voulez
si l'entreprise est condamnée donc il y
a des sommes ils peuvent être versés
justiciables et donc ça ça doit se faire
à travers l'association de consommateurs
ce qui est pas vraiment notre rôle
d'accord et concernant les autres
actions à mettre en place qu'elles sont
d'après UFC les priorités
de la santé et également tout ce qui est
lié à la protection de l'environnement
ça c'est pas possible je reviens
concernant ce que disait Benoît Hamon
sont des parkings et les autorodateurs
les choses comme ça c'était prévu dans
la loi progressivement ça avance bien
donc tout à fait grosso modo c'est
satisfaisant
donc demain il y a ce colloque qui a
lieu à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin entre 14h et 17h30 elle a
faculté de droite sciences politiques on
va parler de quoi durant ce colloque
vous allez faire effectivement le bilan
et poser des questions nous avons été
invités donc par les par les professeurs
de l'université et donc le but donc
c'est dans le cadre d'un scolarité des
étudiants c'est une conférence débat un
échange et donc sur les avantages les
avancées permise par la loi Hamon dans
le domaine de l'action de groupe voir ce
que ça apporte quelles sont les
insuffisances et les problèmes
juridiques que ça pose donc pour tout
savoir sur la loi Hamon mes rendez-vous
demain entre 14 h et 17h30 à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
faculté de droits et de sciences
politiques merci beaucoup Philippe venue
sur le plateau de Téléfilm ce journal
est maintenant terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi l'information revient demain en
direct à 18h à 18h30 vous avez
rendez-vous avec le 7 8 politique et ne
manquez pas évidemment à 19h le débat en
direct avec les quatre candidats du
canton de Montigny un débat présenté par
Wilfried Richie je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée